some say transfer learning is the next
driver for the national x-axis but what
we are actually transferring transfer
there most of you probably say the
teachers presented well it's mined out
the other but for today mrs. Foreman is
asphalt
first I will give a bit of introduction
for those of you who are familiar with
transferred at me and I was pain was the
church in health care industry I resent
and experiments designed and you know
where to find out where transfer I
present the results and practical
conclusions before we start though my
name is Andy how my background is
computer science
over the years I have been working on
men and R&D projects mainly related to
computing high performance computing and
bioinformatics and for the for more than
three years now I've been working
project later to deter right so what is
transfer dirty transfer learning can
defined as the improvement of learning
in a new task through the transfer
knowledge from related tasks that has
already been learned in other words we
don't have to train our deep learning
model from scratch we can take one of
the others that were pre-trained on a
better version of it publicly available
data set and hopefully reuse some or
even most of the features in our own
settings where we don't have at much the
benefits of transfer learning about now
we can train our model in the shorter
time using class data moreover our model
may end up higher accuracy and this is
kind of always also tend to generalize
better so this all sounds really great
isn't it
as a result transfer learning may be a
particular from natural images has
become a de facto standard in medical
imaging however we also know that
transfer learning will work best if the
features that have aware useful to solve
from an egg are also useful or
also tell Erica not to be used to solve
for the beam and he will come to the
main challenge in healthcare when we
look at natural images and compare them
to healthcare images with me that Lisi
they have not much in common as a result
as a result features that are useful for
natural images may not be that useful
for our help languages which are much
more specific therefore the question is
have you benefit from models that were
pre trained on natural images to improve
the performance of our healthcare models
right in order to find out we design
fuel experience for we start out with
two first select a task so all tasks and
our going to solve the quite frankly we
went for the most straightforward image
classification for several reasons first
of all is shockingly easy to find public
dataset to evaluate this problem and
more data sets
the better you can generalize moreover I
also strongly believe they are not
focusing just on image classification
here because that plus seven volts our
networks can also be used for object
detection point is even other
imagination tests so we would ask select
that let's talk a bit about experiments
now so first of all we are just that in
what's the impact of networking services
on the model performance so we'll be
comparing the same networks chain and
same dataset first initialize either
ratably
of all different words in a second
experiments we would like to see whether
the free trade weights can actually be
reused as they are or not will be trying
to achieve that but reading second part
of the treatment Network and thank you
the others just receive all the features
from those pros and lighters can be
directly used and was the impact on the
motor performance one note here is that
whenever I mention region twice actually
incurred for the English networks which
is de facto standard in computer vision
up right so instead of conversion
networks and is a networks that are
basically two but work well on the huge
net dataset as you can see we've got two
large and relatively small models with
respect to the parameters and in
addition design was small custom CNN
just to see whether small and focused or
complete with the large networks that
were designed for tough problems and the
history and the vector of the small for
a small basically because it's very
simple we've got basically four blocks
is consisting of a motion really
personal and possible which is all
followed by
so very very straightforward inspector
but probably the most important and our
data sets so power experiments
we selected three medical data sets the
first one assist of images of small
patches of images that I used polish to
Authority cancer detection and this is
basically a binary classification
problem we don't have cancer or not and
as you can see of us pretty well
represented severe problems key bars
outside the second dataset consists of
retinal images so this type of images
that is used for diagnosed in Canada 813
party which sexually during also
blindness it's extremely small dataset
visca it's got less than four thousand
images
these are very luxurious and they are
spread across five ten classes in an
embossed way and the first dataset so
even just a microscope images coming
from the human progress and this was so
very small dataset of less than fifteen
thousand images yes that across 17 in
most classes
additionally your thought that to
society checkers wanted to have one
because it is not religious and you went
for the very famous cats versus dogs
painter said this is of course a percept
in our case however we wanted to have
one not probably just just to see how
things would work if we played
anthologies so in total four data sets
with different number of classes images
and resolutions
some of the data sets are more vast than
the others for which data server we or
we each dataset I was invited to train
by additional test subsets transfer
option importantly in order to account
for custom plans our default default
metric would be area under the ROC curve
Eddie bit about training clergy we
applied some pretty standard for image
processing and augmentation techniques
we wanted to keep it simple and we
didn't pay that much attention you have
a comment to make the sons that we
however he wanted to see was able to
transfer them other than standing we
didn't want to spend like weeks on
hypercar or 300 factors for each
specific dataset and those our dataset
are rather we'll take half and basically
wanted first of all to see what was the
impact of transfer learning so that's
what we went for the standard paper
parameters with the categorical person
shopping as was function
Adam optimizer and public configurations
were 24:53 ebooks actually the only high
parameter costume was the learn trade
and so we wanted to learn so we know
that each dataset and has a correct
learning rate not the small flag but
just right for the
of myself steady additionally I think
it's worth mentioning here that in case
we use the pre-trained that works for
the first three epochs
we only train the dance tires as
possible forward classification with
logic behind credit and only afterwards
starting from epoch pork we train the
rest of the lives of kitchen pliers and
with the default learning rate otherwise
when the network was trained from start
we use the default lemon plate from the
very beginning so this is a pretty
standard approach in transporter but in
any weights or
as for the technologies that we call the
never-ending thirst about to zero on
title and patients were on our high
performance but illegitimate and
especially so of all temptations to
occur for days using 16 um hundred views
so just for you to imagine that we think
roughly two months on a single view on
how many GP so it's quite other
computations right so we've come now to
the interesting part results and at
first we like to compare two settings
same networks changing the same way with
the same hardware parameters on the same
day just as just achievement in
sensation random or or literate web
avoid speech make an image that so here
you can see quite a lot of aggregated
results so maybe that's focus first on
the upper left chance for for a while
also the blue and the orange lines here
represent the training and validation
performance for the treatment at Hawks
and in a similar way the green and red
lines here
and training and validation performance
but the same that folks just train with
randomization so what we can see here
the first observation is that pretend
networks tend to Train much faster for
each vapors second observation can be if
you compare the violation curves because
we can see that is that pre trained
networks that to reach higher level on
the validation dataset and then for
those networks trained construction
photos we can also see that the
appreciate networks a much more stable
in the sense of the confidence interval
between individual brands the confidence
interval smart materials gray area the
spotless there was much lower of the
Baroness versus much longer for those
controls and that were
to the treatment in this case it's much
more stable or predictable and last but
not least I think if you look at the
performance of this small
custom-designed sienna and also see that
it performs just as well if not better
than the large networks trained from
scratch I've also so tempted to quantify
this we can get from the prearranged
network and by speed-up I mean how much
faster a pre-trained how much faster in
terms of epochs a pre trained network
can achieve at least the same level of
validation per performance as the same
network just trained from scratch and
depending on data set we achieved speed
up between 4 and 10 X which is quite a
nice result I would say if you look at
the cuts versus dogs data said this is
very different data set as you know with
natural images and we can see much
higher speed up here and however it
stands to reason because the image net
was trained on this kind of images yeah
but anyway even for our healthcare
images we are still getting quite nice
benefits right let's have a look for a
while on a test set so this is the
inference phase run on the best Check
Point safe throughout the whole training
process so for the cancer and threaten
our data sets we can see we've got
around 5% of improvement from the pre
train networks yes however this doesn't
have to always be the case for instance
for the protein data set sometimes we
cannot clearly distinguish whether it's
better to train from scratch or from
image net weights
tings looks obviously very different for
cats versus dogs later set where we are
getting quite a lot of improvement by
using the pre-trained net interestingly
when we again look at the small CNN we
can see that it performs more or less
the same as the large networks that were
trained from scratch right so we've
learned that initializing network with
pre-trained Nets can improve the
performance of our training even in
healthcare settings so now we've been
interested in how much of this
improvement comes from the actual
feature reuse so we've designed an
experiment in which we were freezing
selected portions of the liar's just to
see whether those fixed features can be
directly reused and what's the impact on
the model performance so what we can see
here is the we can see here validation
curves for the cancer data set and first
of all it's plain to see that regardless
of the network type the best performance
can only be achieved if we fine-tune all
the liars as interestingly even if we
freeze like 10% of the liars that are
closest to the network input we
immediately see quite a large decrease
in the model performance so that
actually suggests that even the most
basic features those features that were
meant to be at most generic ones cannot
be directly reused in our healthcare
settings to some extent this can also be
visualized by running Disney on the pan
ultimate
lier of our network and they can hear we
can see
so these charts were generated for the
concert has said running on inception v3
and we can again see here that even if
you find you know 90% of the liars and
freeze just 10% our clusters are not
that clear meaning that the features
that are produced by the network and not
as you are not that useful to
distinguish between can service versus
non-cancer images and only if you find
you know basically the entire network we
can clear we can clearly see like much
better clusters let's say just to
mention the results for the for the
other healthcare datasets are basically
very very similar so the conclusions are
basically the same and things are
looking very different for the cats
versus dogs data set were regardless of
the numbers of frozen liars the network
was extremely good at distinguishing
between cats versus dogs and if we
visualize this we can again see that
even if you freeze all the liars in the
network the model is actually perfect
and distinguishing between these two
classes right so on one hand we've
learned that initializing the network
with pre-trained weights can greatly
improve our model even in healthcare
settings on the other hand we've learned
that even the most basic features cannot
be reused as they are so what's the
matter well it turns out that even if
you destroy all the image net features
and simply inherit the scaling of the
weights we can get a pretty good
conversion speed so in these charts we
can see the validation performance
during depending on the Train step so
the blue a line here represents the
training from scratch from random
initialization the the orange line
represents the same but the network was
initialized with image net weights and
importantly the green line here
represents the training where all the
images and features were destroyed only
the scaling was preserved and the mean
and variance of the scaling for each
filter and we can clearly see that using
only the scaling of the pre-trained
weights can actually improve the
convergence speed of the network right
and here we've come to conclusions so
the main takeaways for you
first of all utilizing network with
pre-trained weights can greatly improve
the speed of training and on average you
know on our medical data sets we saw the
improvement on the level or on the level
of 7x secondly image that initialize
networks almost always achieved higher
performance on test set and again on our
medical data set and average improvement
was over 4 percent which is
non-negligible number if you're if
you're metric is already above point
nine four point nine and third the image
net features may not be that reusable or
may not be that generic as we previously
thought
but extremely good starting point for
your training so basically to find you
on the entire network but statistically
it was extremely good insulation or
starting point for the neural network
last but not least small customly
designed
conversion networks can also chew very
good results on healthcare datasets so
in our experiments the network that we
designed a small network it performed
just as well as the large networks that
were trained from scratch let me also
suggest that the large networks that
were designed specifically for the image
net are simply over parameterised for
for the problem and as a main takeaway I
would recommend that you that you use
transfer learning in your projects
because it actually is the next driver
of machine learning commercial success
thank you thank you very much ah do you
have any questions yeah thank you for
the talk I have a question about
actually freezing the very first layers
of the ones very close to the input what
was the original size of images actually
I'm very curious about the ratio of
pixels whether actually the ratio
influenced the very basic features so if
you scale to a square and the original
picture was not a square how much this
kind of change influence the result it's
a very interesting question thank you
especially in medicine were some small
like even Dixon pixel wise elements can
influence the result so we went for the
like vanilla vanilla architectures
inception ResNet and we've been scaling
down actually the images to the default
resolution of the network and for the
cancer data set the pictures were pretty
small like 96 by 96 and we haven't been
doing an upscaling
the global average pulling that did the
job so we've been actually scaling down
the image images all the images to
default resolution of the network so we
actually did not look at what's the
impact of this on the change of the
features okay thank you and have you
actually have any rectangle images in
your or all of them were square simply
bigger or smaller let me get back
because the pre-trained architectures
have Square as the input so the protein
data set was was square retina almost
square it's not the original like ratio
it was changed for the presentation just
and cancer was squared interestingly
cuts versus dogs is not square okay okay
have you tried with different number
than three epochs before actually
changing the learning rate this is due
to the very first slides of your
presentation
to be honest no we've for some time
we've been starting to train the network
without freezing the pre-trained liars
and just as start to train the entire
network from the very beginning this
worked as well however the convergence
bit was not that fast because we're at
the beginning destroying that bit
pre-trained features which is not really
good i think some some people some in
some papers they recommend to freeze the
pretreat layers for five epochs but it's
a row of tamp so we went for three
thank great so thank you very much for
the presentation it was super super
interesting and my question is do you
actually are actually some institutions
or hospitals that are using the stuff
that you are creating I mean are there
doctors that actually utilize this kind
of tools
not exactly this research but what
surprised me that a first couple of
papers on transfer learning can
healthcare and guess what surprised me
is they in most of the cases they
actually use the image that pre-trained
wait so that was one of the reasons I
wanted em these are not real images and
these are like medical images so it
doesn't fit very well so that was one of
the reasons I actually wanted to see
what's going on here so we are not
directly using this anywhere because
this was an RD project was just finished
two weeks ago but I hope we will be
using this knowledge somewhere in the
future
hi thanks very much for the talk it's
really really interesting
I'm just wondering whether you thought
it would be useful to have kind of like
a medical specific image datasets are
like medical night instead of image that
of course it's always better if you're
if the data set from on which we are pre
training is similar to to your case the
problem is that the medical data sets
are not open as not role images and I
think that's one of the reasons why
currently the image net is so popular
even in healthcare if we had a model
that is pre trained or more
domain-specific images that would be
great
but we don't have that that kind of free
change model now thank you
thank you very much meow for your speech
[Applause]